No,
Jamie can understand that.
Do you understand Jamie?
He's on black Twitter.
Gucci.
What?
What else is the shit?
Gucci off whites.
Huge right now.
Kratos still good.
Proudest was like,
are there a certain watches that guys tried to wear?
Rolex is always killing it.
This is never going to go and it never goes anywhere.
You got I up Rolex and you're a rapper.
You're a winner.
Yeah.
Yeah,
right.
Always but is classic.
But if you're like a Floyd Mayweather,
you gotta take it to a two level.
Tom Can Louie baton,
he wears a Louis Vuitton and Gucci.
Gucci ski like Cotton,
the street.
She's like number one.
It's a crossover.
How do you know this?
Because the,
their style,
it's just,
you'll see it in the magazines.
Is there like where's it coming out?
The get out there.
I don't know.
It's just you have your finger on the pulse,
but where's the,
where's the,
what magazine do you have to repulse is like what kind of the pulse will start
with like what's the website?
This is,
this is him with this is millions of dollars with a watch has played this cause
it's so preposterous starting from the beginning and play it.
He's so ridiculous.
He's got like 30 watches with it.
But you do it from the beginning.
What's that?
I can't start it over.
Okay,
look at this.
Do you know the kind of security has to have you this,
but you know what?
You know what was crazy?
It's eight days.
30 watches,
10 more days.
I take Tim more watches.
Jesus Christ.
I say fuck it.
If I want to bring up the one and only you're not bringing out the Washington
cost 18 million.
Ah.
Oh my God.
That's so preposterous.
$18 million on her wrist.
That's insane.
Plus the press play Jamie.
I said,
oh you fucker.
Hey today I'm gonna go fuck off $50,000 cause I ain't got shit else to do.
You mother fuckers moneymate Oh all motherfucking day.
The that's ridiculous.
Crazy million dollar watch 50 cent or is that an act?
It's a good question.
That's a real thing.
I think they're really mad at each other.
Yeah.
I don't think,
it seems like the 50 cent and a lot of people get in and a little scraps.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Florida gets them scraps.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
when you act like that,
that's his,
this whole thing.
I hate you.
But the problem is like,
Adrian Broner tries to doing the same thing,
but he doesn't win.
So it's tough.
You know his,
his club is,
I think his slogans about billions.
He's ruined boner ab about billions stuff.
It's a tough sell.
Well,
if he was lighting everybody up on fire,
sorry,
little shit.
But Jamie's mixing it up.
Shit,
I DJ Jv.
Jay was at black Twitter.
Adrian Broder.